nei prossimi dieci minuti o poco più
cercherò di mettere insieme vari
tasselli di un puzzle che a prima vista
non sembrano combaciare parlerò infatti
di tumori e di musica
parlerò di laser e ultrasuoni parlerò di
cellule e vibrazioni se lascerò il mio
intento però alla fine avrò dipinto un
quadro per spiegarvi come è possibile
usare i laser per far vibrare le
molecole ascoltare il suono che fanno
e così identificare i tumori ecco
partiamo proprio dai tumori
oggi la diagnosi di un tumore è
generalmente è affidata ad un patologo
un medico specialista di laboratorio e
quello che si fa e prendere un campione
di tessuto trattarlo con dei coloranti
di contrasto e guardarlo visivamente al
microscopio
questa potrebbe essere una un risultato
è di esempio vedete che nella parte
bassa c'è una proliferazione di cellule
che indica appunto alla presenza di un
tumore mentre la porzione superiore è
sana
il difficile compito del patologo non è
solo quello di localizzare il tumore
distinguono dalla parte sana appunto ma
è anche e soprattutto quello di
identificarne la caratteristica la
tipologia specifica tra le più di 100
tipologie di tumori esistenti ovviamente
fare una diagnosi corretta è
fondamentale per poter intraprendere un
percorso di cura mirato e quindi più
efficace purtroppo per certi tumori oggi
questo è difficile ad esempio a volte 2
patologi si trovano in disaccordo sulla
diagnosi dello stesso pezzo di tessuto
ecco che allora il mio compito è il
seguente col mio gruppo di ricerca sto
intraprendendo un percorso finanziato
dalla comunità europea per cercare in
qualche modo in futuro di sostituirsi al
ruolo del patologo ora non me ne voglia
la categoria non voglio togliere loro il
lavoro
lo scopo è quello di realizzare un
microscopio come potrebbe essere questo
che in futuro possa entrare in sala
operatoria
oppure in uno studio medico che permetta
di fare una diagnosi di un tessuto
a rischio eventualmente identificarne il
tumore se presente in maniera non
invasiva quindi senza dover rimuovere il
tessuto né danneggiarlo
e soprattutto in tempi rapidi cioè senza
dover aspettare lunghi esame di
laboratorio
ora com'è possibile fare tutto questo
grazie a questo signore chandrasekar
rahman premio nobel indiano per la
fisica nel 1930 rahman ha scoperto un
fenomeno fisico che porta appunto il suo
nome è l'effetto rahman l'effetto rahman
serve per identificare chimicamente una
molecola di cui ho fatto il tessuto
sotto esame
perché a un certo suono speriamo di
spiegarlo in questa maniera
prendiamo una molecola di acqua che la
molecola più comune è facile e due atomi
di idrogeno un atomo di ossigeno e
pensiamo di prendere un martelletto e
colpire la molecola di acqua
ecco la vedremo vibrare in maniera
caotica apparentemente senza senso
eppure se la scomponiamo nelle sue
componenti principali scopriamo che
invece vibra secondo delle vibrazioni
più semplici
il primo modo è questo e vediamo che fa
una specie di respiro nel senso che le
distanze si allungano e si accorciano
periodicamente il secondo modo di
vibrare dell'acqua è il seguente fa una
specie di flessioni nel senso che si
apre e si chiude periodicamente come
fosse un paio di forbici
cosa vuol dire tutto questo lo capiamo
se facciamo un esempio prendiamo una
chitarra
se suoniamo una corda di chitarra
sentiremo una nota
ecco questa nota in realtà non è una
frequenza pura un suono puro ma è
l'insieme di tante frequenze che vibrano
insieme per le molecole è un po la
stessa cosa
colpendo una molecola con un martelletto
la faremo vibrare secondo tante
frequenze caratteristiche che sono come
dei suoni che qui ho identificato con
queste onde gialle che si propagano
verso l'esterno
l'insieme delle frequenze che vibrando
insieme formano questo movimento si
chiama a timbro
ecco il timbro quello che ci permette ad
esempio di distinguere il suono di un
pianoforte da suono di una chitarra
analogamente se ascoltiamo due persone
che parlano e dicono la stessa frase al
telefono sappiamo distinguere chi ha
parlato
perché anche le persone come gli
strumenti musicali hanno un timbro
caratteristico potremmo dire una voce
caratteristica ecco per le molecole
succede esattamente la stessa cosa
una mole quella vibrando vibra secondo
un caratteristico timbro abbiamo visto
per l'acqua che non ha un solo modo di
vibrare ma respirava e faceva le
flessioni
ora se prendiamo una molecola più
complessa come potrebbe essere una di
queste due proteine allora potrà vibrare
secondo una serie di frequenze molto più
complesse alcune più forti altri meno
che possiamo utilizzare per
identificarle univocamente come prima
possiamo identificare il pianoforte una
chitarra dal suo timbro così anche
queste due molecole molto complesse
suonano diverso ad esempio se colpiamo
la prima potremo sentire un pezzo di
pianoforte
e invece se colpiamo la seconda sentiamo
una chitarra elettrica
ecco allo stesso modo quindi possiamo
identificare le molecole classe al
processo rahman perché suonano in
maniera diversa
allora a questo punto possiamo ad
esempio guardare una cellula come questa
e ad esempio se conosciamo che sono file
dna ci sintonizziamo sulla sua frequenza
e andiamo a fare una mappa della
concentrazione del dna come questa in
viola e vediamo che è soprattutto
concentrato nel nucleo perché lì il
suono è più forte se invece ci
sintonizziamo sul suono delle proteine
qui in blu vedremo un'altra mappa di
concentrazione e così anche per il pd
che sono i grassi che vediamo essere
concentrati soprattutto in questi
puntini verdi che vediamo in basso che
sono appunto zone di accumulo di lipidi
e alla fine facciamo un immagine in
falsi colori che era quarta che una
sovrapposizione delle prime tre
ora ci rimane ci manca da capire che
suono fanno le molecole per capirlo
torniamo all'esempio della chitarra se
noi ora tocchiamo il tasto di una
chitarra
accorciamo la corda accorciando la corda
e sono sarà più acuto
ecco ora se noi potessimo accorciare
ancora di più la corda fino a farla
diventare così piccola come una molecola
di acqua il suono sarebbe acutissimo in
altre parole le molecole gli atomi della
molecola di acqua devono fare delle
distanze nella sua vibrazione molto
piccole e quindi tempo per fare queste
distanze per compere queste distanze
molto breve
se il tempo a breve lo possono fare
tante volte al secondo quindi la
frequenza e acuta acutissima e così
acuta che ai 20 milioni di volte più
alta di quanto possiamo ascoltare noi
col nostro orecchio
quindi ci vuole un orecchio direi da
supereroe un orecchio a ultrasuoni in
realtà non si usa un orecchio altra
suoni per ascoltare il suono delle
molecole ma si usa un laser e questo è
proprio il mio lavoro io non sono un
medico o un musicista o un esperto di
acustica ma sono un fisico che lavora
con il laser e laser in questo processo
non serve solo per ascoltare il suono
delle molecole ma serve anche
soprattutto per metterle in vibrazione
infatti il suono è così elevato la sola
nota è così acuto
che anche il martelletto che colpisce la
molecola per farla vibrare e deve dare
un colpo secco rapido rapidissimo più
rapido di quanto noi possiamo immaginare
ed oggi lo strumento più rapido mai
inventato dall'uomo è proprio il laser e
laser e infatti si può accendere e
spegnere e una frazione infinitesima di
secondo tic tac è come se fosse un flash
di una macchina fotografica ma molto
molto più rapido per capire quanto
rapido un flash di una macchina
fotografica come il laser
basti pensare che è così breve che
rispetto a un minuto di tempo quanto un
minuto di tempo sta all'età intera di un
universo
oppure come questa moneta da un
centesimo e poco rispetto all'intero
debito pubblico italiano
dura un milionesimo di miliardesimo di
secondo è l'evento più breve ma
realizzato dell'uomo ecco che allora
concentrando così tanta luce in così
poco tempo questa luce colpisce la
molecola la mette in vibrazione e
possiamo sentirne il suono e poi io mi
occupo proprio di questo di laser
sviluppo nuovi sistemi di laser per
mettere in vibrazione le molecole
potremmo dire che sono una specie di
musicista molecolare da 15 anni lavoro
in laboratorio questo è il laboratorio
in cui lavoro sono quello di dietro a
sinistra e ho fatto diversi studi mi
sono occupato di capire ad esempio dei
processi di base della fisica come la
fotosintesi oppure i processi di base
della visione umana ma da un po di anni
stavo cercando un problema che fosse
anche utile stanno cercando un problema
che avesse dei risvolti pratici
importanti per la società è stato un po
un processo di serendipity potremmo dire
serendipity un termine coniato da questo
scrittore inglese alla fine del
settecento che potremmo definire come il
trovare una cosa non cercata in prevista
mentre se ne stava cercando un'altra
ecco io ero tutto concentrato a
sviluppare nuovi laser che poi mi sono
accorto un po per caso un po per fortuna
che questo poteva essere applicato per
qualcosa di utile che era lo studio dei
tessuti e l'analisi tumorale con il mio
gruppo di ricerca e altri nel mondo
stiamo quindi cercando di sviluppare un
innovativo sistema di microscopia in
grado di analizzare i tessuti e
identificare i tumori i primi risultati
sono molto incoraggianti
vedete ad esempio qui due risultati di
identificazione tumorale
nel primo caso di un tumore della pelle
nel secondo un tumore del cervello e
questo è stato possibile semplicemente
ascoltando solo due o tre acustiche
frequenze acustica solo 23 note delle
molecole che stavano vibrando cosa manca
quindi adesso manca la possibilità di
estendere la capacità di ascoltare
questi suoni e quindi ascoltare tutta
l'interezza della musica che emettono le
molecole e così non solo trovare dove il
tumore ma a identificarne precisamente
la caratteristica la sua tipologia e
secondo serve farlo in tempi rapidi
cioè serve avere una risposta in pochi
minuti
in questa maniera in futuro sarà
possibile fare un'identificazione
tumorale in tempi brevi qualitativa e
quantitativa oggettiva riproducibile e
così migliorare l'esito degli interventi
oppure delle possibili inter diciamo
interventi delle cure antitumorali
ecco diciamo che questo è quindi il mio
progetto di ricerca che spero diventi
una realtà
nei prossimi dieci anni grazie